やっぱて最近全然 twitter 読んでなかった今日買ってきました
あの肇社長の漫画の第4巻が出てますね
買ってきてくれてありがとうございます面白いのでぜひ読んでみてください多分で本屋
に売ってると思う
何してるの今動画とってますこれじゃあまた社長で今日はですねちょっと皆さんに質問
というかお話しつつ全然頭を見てれてるだけ
はですね皆さんに少し
ご相談というかちょっとねどうしらいいんだろうと思ってることがあってちょっと聞い
てみたいと思います
あの静岡で生活してはや何年だろう
18歳の時に来たからについて232425
もう7年も静岡いるわけですよもうこんだけ長い時間静岡にいるとやっぱり静岡の
居心地が良すぎて申し上げ
増加し考えれねーなーと思っちゃったんですけど意外というの中そうじゃねえなって時
に思うことがありまして
やっぱり結局内海の東京に行くことが多いんですよきっとこの先も多いと思うんでね
やっぱ猫の家も ec を屋さんもいいんですけど
モーセ仮ですよもし仮にこれ以上があるとは思ってないんですけどもし仮にこれ以上
良い場所が東京に米近くてすぐ行けるような場所が通して動画が撮れ
て環境がもしあったらめちゃくちゃいいなと思いましてもうそこにはもう一クズしか
ねえなって思っちゃったんですよあればですけどね皆さん
いいとこないですかちょっとでも理想化がでかいんだよなぁとりあえずも住んで次に
引っ越しするとしたらね
庭付きであってほしいでっかいにはで動画撮りたいで中には付きの物件だったらいい
なっていう感じです
外で撮影したソトが目立ったことするとすごい盗撮とかね人がきちゃって普通だとでき
ないですよね
ず普通だとできない外での撮影をできるよう
大きなにはが欲しい何とか守ったりしてるんですけどそういう武器があればなーって
いいなぁと思っちゃって
そこからセパ大事なのは東京への近さ静岡からだとだいたい1時間半以上か包んで1
時間以内とかに付けたらめちゃくちゃいいなとか思ったりしててどこがいいんだろうっ
ていうのとわかんないちょっとちゃベアー
はいでは探していきます
ゴールどこにいるんだろう全部現在ちゃう綾部住所てチャー住所でしょじゃバリバリ
ズってちゃうじゃんこれすらすらもざっくりもういいや
まあざっくりというね
僕は今ざっくり日本でいうと深いもここら辺にいるわけですよ
東京までね結構でもね思ってる近いですよね静岡って本当に場所で東京を使い3
流れ落ち会や日本人と話してみると割とねー
おっとウラジオストク日本の真ん中なんですよね静岡ってからどこにでもね行きやす
いっちゃ行きやすいっていう絶妙な
頭に時差住んでおりますでこっから東京に近づくとなるとまず
名古屋浜松方面はないとして神奈川千葉東京山梨埼玉群馬当時茨城あたりかなとか思っ
ちゃったりしてますそれか箱根とか中とかそこらへんもいいんだよなんて東京付近で何
か良い場所がないかなと思ってるんですよ
白とかありなんだよ実際後
3もありやなぁのだから熱海あたり所で号結構いいのかなと思いつつ4橋付近だと
やっぱ最多のと方もいいんだよね地元のテーマに帰る作成もありと思うんですけどもと
やだから到底クってなると国はと言って糸魚川いい
て新潟入っちゃって今パーッとおりって長野超えて高崎群馬とか言ってガーンと降りて
おりておりて練馬区そして東京に着くという流れなんで遠くなっちゃうわけですよ
ちょっと山に帰って戦は今のところずっとはないかなと思っておりますうっトレード
条件としては東京になれなく今いる
a よりかは使い方がいいかなと思っております
それだね海沿いね王さんビューとかなと思うんですよね
東京ディズニーシーですね東京て dc が近くにするっていうの作品的にはアリです
ね
高そうだなぁちょっと都心はやめとこうかなと ol をする物語だだからその東京の
真ん中だとた君音には月の大きないるとかないと思うんでやっぱりちょっと下がってる
神奈川と結構実際あるべきか済んだよね江ノ島行ったことないから行ってみたいんです
よ
箱根とかってさ実際どうなんですかねお店のは小田原とかで結構れると思うよ
ただいま
住んでるとこーっと東京のさらに間何で近いっちゃ近い車でも行けそう
電車でもシンカフェの行けそうな距離ではあります
小田原にしようかな逆に回っちゃって何か作ろうとかさあサイダー度に映って作詞も
あるしそういう山梨とかに逃げちゃってもういい気持ますちょっとねまだわかんない
なぁいいという感じで実はですね
ベゼ引っ越せしようとしてるわけじゃないんですけどもう距離いくつかくなって今より
なんかいい感じだったら別に僕は引っ越してもいいのかなとは思っておりますからね
ああもしこしたくないんですよね正直もうこの家がねほど良すぎて
4つ切り白谷さんの人すぎでも出たくないんです
東京なってるという間
でももう本当にね息を削るしかないなと思っているんだよどうもがいいんですよね保守
的にいいところがあったら本当に何かそこらへんの物件とはされたいなと思ってるん
ですけども
パンねーなーでも引っ越せたらいいなっていう気がしてますやばいなーこれも良いし頭
を離れるときが近づいているのかもしれない
わかんないですけどいいと神つかなかったらほんと母艦ここが一番いいと思ってるんで
いい場所
た教えてくださいでも出たくないんだよなぁもうどっちなんだってね
ああ
[音楽]
じゃまずね何県にすべくを決めたいんだよなおすすめの件とか
場所があったら教えてくださいなるべく東京に近かったら
うれしいなじゃあ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ